troisième de maladie mais plutôt une
excitation
d'abord la dictée car la journée est
dédiée à l'association ela qui lutte
contre les leucodystrophies
mais le texte évoque aussi toutes les
différences et les stigmatisations
encore trop présente dans la vie
quotidienne dans ce collège d'un
quartier très populaire et parfois
tumultueux l'opération englobe plusieurs
objectifs
ce qu'on souhaite vraiment c'est de les
ouvrir aux autres ils sont dans un
établissement où la cité juste à côté
ils sont trés enfermés dans leur cité
dans leur mode de d'agir et on veut
vraiment les ouvrir à autre chose une
ouverture aux autres aux différences au
respect des uns des autres et la
musculation
l'athlétisme le regard des autres même
bienveillant et souvent un poids pour
l'athlète en situation de handicap à 26
ans nicolas ramond nageur puis athlètes
handisport connaît toujours des
difficultés liées à sa différence les
préjugés pour un garçon qui a dû se
construire avec un grave traumatisme
crânien continuent de jalonner son
existence en fait quand on dit que que
je suis pas que cette ça va être trop
dur c'est
à l'équipe du film handicap moi je leur
dis merci
parce que c'est grâce à ça que j'essaie
de pousser un peu jusque jusqu'au bout
et
pour nicolas ramond l'objectif est
d'être présent aux jo de paris dans
trois ans une ambition guidé par
l'exemple du canoéiste orléanais remy
boulet médaillé de bronze en septembre
paralympiques de tokyo une réussite qui
prouve que la devise olympique plus vite
plus haut plus fort est tout aussi
applicable aux handisports
[Applaudissements]